oh my god junk inside all right I'll get
younger stone I'm plea to a gala because
I'm gonna heal me hey guys welcome back
to the couch I'm Dave I'm Tom and I'm
sick this is sick still but she's
decided to come and infect us because we
said we were going to be playing
overwatch drunken Stein's revenge we
might have some issues though yeah we
all play on PC uh this isn't a keyboard
this is not a keyboard a mouse so I'm
gonna be spending like half the game
going where's the e it's not sorry
either so I'm like what who are these
other people that's it i'm gonna play as
honor you in pairs hands own McCree Cree
all right I don't think we're gonna
finish but we're gonna get a good shot
it's let's get going all right get your
characters for someone snatches I've got
hands o.o Cree gazelle-like an MP
soldier I would never ever ever players
hands oh I'm Pete yeah there's
somebody's goes toes I think they should
make a skin like this version of McCree
it looks pretty cool like black just
just play it over watch right yeah you
know maybe back away yeah no it's cuz
like I'm pc i find it way too fiddly to
play his hands over as i feel it's a lot
more it's not easier on the console
because all the weight is a thing yeah
let me not just that but like it's a
little slower I need to get used to the
the controls I don't know what's what
okay then I just had to scope in and
immediately punch the air all right I'm
gonna okay so for those of you have not
played Junkins lines revenge it's your
joy machine to pumpkin Stein Lucy I'm
not frank enstein is we've basically
just gotta buy it all have you never
seen loosen the movie focus i'm giving
away objectives Padma yeah but like the
door is important right old safe for the
door ancient wood it's an antique
pensive it's older than time itself what
like grandmother will own you make some
really old people references yes o
goddess hey when's Pocahontas karana
yeah but like all the kids our age watch
that
get that reference hey what you doing
over there I'm missing the sonic what do
you do not you I'm talking about the
Dominic if you need heels just give me a
shout I mean signal gazelle com because
he's just a random we picked up to fill
the gap but Wow way to make him feel at
home bring it out it's this upon his
back economist oh crap I he's made he's
been a pretty decent soldier so far sir
occupy cuz we have played against some
garbage oh yeah I think all the
teammates yeah wait for my outlet yeah
you did I was gonna draw attention to it
but I'm saving my alt for the boss yeah
whoever's going out when the bus comes
I'm just gonna Oh God because oh those
are as a tf2 reference I'm a dental got
a dog gosh no more guarding yeah I
forgot that the RIP tire isn't aiming
for me yeah it's really weird like you
where do it before it gets the doors
like oh it's coming for me but I'm
create and I'd the Kree can stun the
tire swing it yeah we're here to change
infection flashbang I say we get out at
you and the soldier have I'm sorry I'd
forget it I like a little story that
they're telling ya the narration is
pretty good we each have like a name as
well I'm The Alchemist on the Archer
Archer my the gun sling mostly throw me
on that yeah the guns think of a
sharpshooter remember olo is this start
presence alright that range Dominic
needs to go all right 03 / alright I've
got my ID like recently gained art he's
got a rope me I've got my own it's
pretty best giving it's a soldier goes
off in it all right you get a time how
did that not get anyone I he ducked this
guy's Seljuk i am the soldier stole the
shop who is killed sorry noble team yeah
right there's no pointy what no there's
no you
wait there's no all the door I am watch
thing huh good work day since that is
here you hate me all that some sweet
oils help me exciting round up a little
too far these waves do you start out
really like oh crap i say this diet aim
but actually got a great damage door oh
boy oh he's sitting where we are time to
heal you move so Rackley there we go
that's what I taught helps tell me to do
another one oh you got it wasting some
heels for loosing ankle okay the samba
dear though yeah he's annoying come on
kids shock top but how did that get all
the way there puts so much get into it
nope all right I'm gonna go on my body
shop you guys mean I'm what unreal TC
well just like watching general um road
hog is my boy you know this but I
thought it might be nice for the video
tomorrow you know this apparently like
the matter is different on consoles
those so who had main on consoles yeah a
different story yeah I played triplanes
Ariane on the console and it was really
weird um cuz i flit around I have like
all right thanks for defending me yeah I
mean you have this road hog skinny mercy
is my current debut but no charge yes so
does got it
he'll yep by painting oh yeah I hate hit
your the heel but this wasn't enough all
right get away from other oh oh my god
there's a lot huh why he's asleep top
how are you still old saying no no
hearing for you there we go no I wasted
my ult know ok I've dolls taken a bit of
a punting door is needing destroyed
already our door could be unlike an
author's in video being redone needs a
bit of touch-up I mean I think we can
hold up hold them off for now but it's
wedding like a final waves come in
trouble there's a boy don't forget about
the repo it's a repo da sneak I'm gonna
focus on drunken Stein range door door
door yeah y'all could take hers don't
need the healer to be able to go Tom who
you i'ma free i'm playing by the door
but there's no no don't forget you can
stunts yep fudge oh my god what oh my
god oh I need heels I can't see you I'm
up here no got you thank you okay joking
started real love p he's so dead god
it's really hard to do the fund a hammer
I'll heal you over here the foot control
the creep please bring sleep you think
nice how come is this bring it home
hmm stressful it really is stressful I
like it that is to doubt it's gonna have
we got both nice work man what's your
favorite thing about over watch all of
it so he'll reef Emma what Scott Irwin
Georgie there are you can he wait
through mine yeah let's come what Ted's
it to a ghost Oh her dose may be
emotionally cat all fire dis him I was
just gonna tell him his mum didn't love
employment geez hello it could you like
the Casper thing Casper dayum rapids in
love old movies yeah what am i knows old
egg I mean you know that they're not
even that all yeah they're like 90s its
twenty sixteen different generation
different world away oh my god i am
missing everything final battle oh oh
this on mercy mercy yes the focus for
this okay I mean also protect the door
yeah hey Chad pick her up but yeah she's
gonna which Panzer you should probably
just focus on the dress Cairo I can turn
up my high noon hands oh ok I'm going
alright Mercy's quite low actually I'm
Honor I got me all right she down might
be good be good oh you to go to sleep
punk i can try to go oh my god junk
inside all right i'll get younger stone
I need to enroll girl I cuz I'm gonna
heal me no no where is he uh he went
Johnny signs miles away sorry I think we
did all right for a first attempt
we can get I come again next time two
hours later I'm just taking me out oh I
am alrighty I'm Rick ah damn it we got
close the last time ok next one got good
for you by the next one oh god sake week
what you have nothing better to do me
there we go no doors on man Canada's go
seeking the truth oh damn it Reapers
here oh my god days oh my god fomba dear
I'm dead rip we suck at this game no no
no no no no no no no Oh God dang it oh
damn it one more Lucy your son to scare
me this isn't healthy breathe Lucy no up
we ended up buried Lucy all right how
many attempts is this we've managed to
screw up listen Dave we tried our
hardest referred so hard playing with a
chanukah yeah for you because of our
handicap in my world I mean you see and
I have kind of adapted so yeah like we
do I don't like it another board I can
adapt to anything nice a little surf it
rougher than that okay Ana's already
show me the healing thing I don't know
that was accidental I'm not oh maybe
it's pre-emptive cautiously optimistic
there isn't like overheal in this ain't
no plastic tf2 where are my bullets
going into the Assam makes I hope a lil
room is fun to shoot that oh yeah heelys
ruckus boom all right these breaks hey
the bomb bit is actually I think I
called zombie days
I'm just pre-emptive like primitively
assuming what comment will be after you
call on the mob it is yes sir Boop
whoops the melee does like no damage yes
the bodies exploded at the door was one
doctored already uh one day via my mom
dear worry let's to hang on this bridge
for the majority of time I think yeah
it's my safe space a happy place or I
kill all these onyx scatter Oh Alan is a
horrible man keep coming oh well I've
been powered up I mean that's not the
same uh labs close enough they're right
listen up no he doesn't last very long
all right then oh my god was gonna move
it right tomorrow it's great trigger to
shoot I've been pressing V all this time
it's on marching over and over again
indeed does be even do coach all right
we had a bit of a moment he sees a good
out about you bring you another user
let's say I use it all the time why to
hide from like spy revival and right
Reapers income in there he is big man
himself macris oh
Death Comes shut the hell up Reaper sit
down go back home to your mama whoever
you live with you may probably move out
your parents house is pointing but
what's like the fan thing in the minute
for repo is that like obviously no wreak
field I have not so basically people
have just made Reaper into a Garfield as
camp oh I have seen repo they've just
made loads of Garfield cartoons but with
wheat field and they are amazing
adorable also like the one with McLean
with the cat yeah and it is it's fine
you oh yeah those get a little all right
got my old back me too all right we're
discolored world every time there's a
shocked I i'm using my dolly shot I
killed it that early I just altered it
so I can shoot it for miles away oh well
I'm at least go get past me it's not
allowed it's not at all or is it worth
it yeah I've got it even hear that one
all right we got that on a nice good
work heading back up to the to the
bridge that's what I feel filled my most
most myself Captain Kirk that one does
got behind everyone came from the right
good month can somebody get out of here
punk punk ass [ __ ] all right we have a
healing slowly healing not good and
that's what we need to go along okay oh
sounds like someone's coming up some
weird catered stuff come in it's cuz i'm
sick and my voice is already oh dang
junk assignments just staring at me some
intimidated by should be ready for me
stop oh wow there's a quite a lot of him
okay I've been focusing Duncan Stein
sorry he's real life I don't to leave
him he'll though he's so low one more
one more item solo no no my god Anna
okay we're good oh I melting I'll take
um in the hood we're a couple you guys
died just then um wow why have I been
great there's literally yeah you need
some health Lucy yeah I think he mean he
meant to heal me but he actually powered
me up all right his is a thing wait I do
oh thanks buddy I'm gonna go to the
bridge and focus him again I wonder if I
could just get up there um
dr. John style of these bombs in the
castle the explosions are endemic are
really like the writing in their net
naruto naruto meritor now know what's
going on yeah I knew you'd pick up
another reaps is back jungle time dad
aah what aah what a helix rocket that
was that was amazing good get your heels
heels everybody oh ok start doing better
some deer get out of town you know rock
and roll I forgot about that on my god I
wondered why you're having such a
problem with reloads jeez this is like
our eighth try that second job a little
more free pink bagus double shock taco
so we can money I'm the syllabary / them
lay off lake boom did you look at the
top up oh oh no oh I got it I got it bad
guys there we go I like when it gets
what it turns like phantom of the opera
music nine seconds left I my father
doing great with doing great guys
excellent work and primary all well I
minute I gotta shoot them from behind
when I'm as he turns up oh how did you
go the past is better My servants they
patched that in the night yeah cuz
everyone available yet no but it sir the
gambia let it bleed I'm sure the witch
okay all right run out oh and i gotta
focus dr. Jenkins Thank junkin Stein
which is almost down she's so dead get
here you your beautiful woman haha oh my
god huh I'm just gonna oh no I got ya
I'm just shooting bounded oh my god I go
and get the witch we're trying so hard
Stan gendercide spam jungle sounds that
good o lads we might actually do this I
don't want to don't jinx it
yeah yeah yeahs myself oh no heal me yes
okay focus that monster down yeah sleep
my ultimate stop it oh yes oh we did it
I noon baby oh that was so tough that
was stressful nobody tell the commenters
that we actually turned it down too easy
for the last one you've just what why
that's fine i did this out sir all right
snow buddies tell anyone me mother Lucy
got blowed again I got one the game that
one again every player the game it's
either this one of the game or its
soldier 76 just aiming down like 20
dominicks you really took your time than
us sure I'd 834 zom Nate kills everyone
knows themself go on loose eve of
yourself you deserve it Thanks yes two
and a half stars lastly had the
Performing apparently we were bang on
average that's why so I aim for Dave
five gold medals Oh mate gold medal for
healing done this by having healer oh
dear well I mean I think I just lost the
entirety of my my hair stressing over
that sounds fun I'm not gonna play again
though I love this game alright guys if
you enjoyed that video make sure you hit
the like button subscribe to games
Klopfer for more videos like this one
and we'll see you next time bye